[Music]
since the end of 2022 we have known that
possibly the last film in the action
series by and with Sylvester Stallone
The Expendables 4 will be released this
year although the three parts released
so far have not been huge hits at the
box office they have certainly provided
some entertainment value especially for
fans of old and new action heroes in
today's Kino check original We summarize
all the key information you need to know
before the release of The Expendables 4.
have fun watching
the plot of the previous three films can
be summed up quite simply The
Expendables are an elite group of
fearless mercenaries perfectly qualified
for the most demanding missions in the
first movie for example they get the
assignment to overthrow a dictator in
South America but soon find out that
their client may have more in mind than
it first appears in the second part The
Expendables also accept the mission that
in retrospect is far more challenging
than anticipated and even claims the
life of their member Billy the Kid
Timmons the group finally takes revenge
and goes Behind Enemy Lines where they
have to deal with an even greater threat
likewise the third part hardly differs
from its predecessors in terms of plot
as the main characters once again have
to deal with a shady character namely
Conrad an arms dealer and former
Expendables he changed sides a while
after the formation of the groove and
now constitutes a threat however the
elite group around leader Barney manages
to overcome this challenge as well as
you can easily see the storyline of the
movies usually follows a reliable
pattern so you should not expect too
many changes in The Expendables 4 but at
least one one difference to the previous
films is already certain that is the
change of the team leader since Barney
Ross actor Sylvester Stallone is now
already 76 years old hardly anybody can
deny that a change in leadership was
long overdue the new Expendables leader
is Jason Statham's character Lee
Christmas which may mean that Stallone's
character will step down right at the
beginning of The Expendables 4 or might
even be killed off to make way for a
successor the latter would at least give
the mercenary Squad another reason to
set out on a merciless Vendetta
traditionally the selection of the cast
is a particularly important aspect of
The Expendables movies as we already
know the two aforementioned actors Jason
Statham and Sylvester Stallone are
reprising the roles for the fourth part
also joining the cast are Dolph Lundgren
as Gunner Jensen and Randy Couture as
toll road additional returnees from the
previous films are not anticipated as a
poster from cinemacon 2022 already
showed the key cast members according to
the poster however the new additions
include Curtis Jackson AKA 50 Cent
Transformer star Megan Fox tie actor
Tony ja and bad boys for Life actor
Jacob Scipio likewise joining the cast
is the raid star Iko owais as arms
dealer and antagonist and Ocean's 11
actor Andy Garcia as an unnamed CIA
agent a return of Terry Crews as hail
Caesar or Arnold Schwarzenegger s trench
is not something we should be expecting
although a surprise appearance is of
course always welcome
the production of The Expendables 4
probably involves the biggest changes
compared to its predecessors as both the
director and the scriptwriter were
changed for Stallone's last appearance
Patrick Hughes is replaced by Need for
Speed director Scott Waugh while the
plot was penned by the trio of Kurt
Wimmer Tad daggerhart and Max Adams this
time around Wimmer last wrote the
screenplay for the 2021 action film The
Misfits while Adams and daggerhardt have
previously been involved in less
familiar films filming ran from the end
of September to the beginning of
December 2021 and took place mainly in
Europe this also means the movie has
already been wrapped for quite a long
time and post-production is probably
nearing completion as well so it's time
to put the remaining funds into the
promotional stage currently fans are
eagerly awaiting the first trailer for
the action spectacle we can then watch
the final outcome on the big screen from
September 22nd 2023. since that's when
The Expendables 4 opens in theaters
that's it for our little update about
the big finale of The Expendables with
Sylvester Stallone let us know your
hopes for the continuation of the series
in the comments is there an action star
who should definitely make an appearance
also leave us a like if you enjoyed this
video and feel free to comment on which
movies you'd like to see more videos
about
foreign
[Music]